I Oh statistician at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center I've been
there for almost eight years now and in
that role I collaborate with oncologists
and surgeons and radiologists and all
other types of clinicians or Kane Cancer
Research to play on their prospective
research studies and analyze
retrospective data and it's a really fun
job I use our for that and a rely very
heavily on our markdown which like saves
my life every time there like I changed
one data point and I can just you know
run my reports again so I will be
talking today about some survival
analysis stuff kind of introducing the
topic and talking about ways that it
survival time data is commonly
misinterpreted or Mis analyzed and some
of the ways you can use our to do it
correctly okay so the most common type
of data I encounter in my work at a
cancer hospital is survival time data
and survival time data is any type of
data that has a start time so in the
work I do that's commonly a date of
diagnosis or a date of treatment start
or a date of surgery and then some
amount of time passes and there's an end
date at which an event of interest
occurs and so when the work I do that's
commonly death or a disease recurrence
or disease progression and there's a
date associated with that so it's kind
of obvious that this type of data would
be common and so in in cancer research
or in any other fields of healthcare
research but it's actually common across
many fields and kind of sometimes I
think it can be a little sneaky and so
people don't know they're dealing with
data that has a time component but in
other healthcare fields like
cardiovascular research and hiv/aids
this is common it's also very common in
social science research there's a lot of
social science endpoints that actually
have a time component your event is
happening and maybe today you ask
someone a question and the answer is no
but the answer could be us tomorrow or
next week or next month and so this time
component is important to consider and
it's very very commonly analyzed
incorrectly so like I just mentioned
survival analysis is common in a lot of
different fields and so that means it
goes by a lot of different names
and we call it in healthcare survival
analysis most of the time sometimes time
to event analysis but it can also be
known as reliability analysis and
duration
analysis or event history analysis and
so these are just some terms you can
watch out for that could clue clue you
in that there's a time component to
something that you're reading about um
you guys but my clock numbers started so
just FYI I'm gonna talk for 20 minutes
but okay so in cancer there are kind of
two main questions that are commonly of
interest to patients so one of the main
things that we do is we analyze data and
the goal is often to generate some
numbers that doctors use to convey
prognostic information to their patients
so it's really important to get this
right and two of the most common things
that quantities that are of interest are
the probability of surviving a certain
number of years so this could be one
year or five years or ten years and then
some estimate of like on you know on
average how long do people with a
certain disease tend to live so just a
very simple example to start we have
five patients here and we're interested
in let's say we're interested in the
five-year probability of survival well
patients one three four and five we're
all followed for the full five years
they were alive at the end of that five
year follow-up and then they were
patient two died at three years so this
is pretty straightforward we can just
take the proportion of patients who died
one out of five and estimate the 5-year
probability of survival of 80% so no
problem here this is straightforward so
the problem comes in and the complexity
comes in when that's not exactly the
case so in the same simple example I've
altered the data for two patients so we
still have patients one in four who are
followed for a full five years and
they're alive at the end of follow-up
patient two died at three years but now
patients three and five have been
followed for less than five years and
the last thing that we knew about them
is that they were alive and this can
this is what's known as censored data
and this can occur for a lot of reasons
it can happen because patients enter a
study late and so then the study ends
and they haven't been followed for the
full amount of time of interest or it
can happen because they entered at the
beginning but for some reason they were
lost to follow up maybe they moved out
of the area or some other reason
it's very common to have this kind of
variation and survival time data and
then in follow-up data and then you know
we want to estimate the 5-year
probability of survival but for patients
3 & 5 in this example at 5 years we
don't know if they were dead or alive
all we know is that at some point in
time before 5 years the last thing we
know about them is that they were alive
so now it's not so straightforward to
get these estimates so I'm gonna be
using an example today throughout my
talk before I get into some R code and
some results it's a kidney cancer data
there's 2119 patients in this data set
it's a retrospectively sampled and we're
interested the event of its gist is just
death from any cause so we're interested
in overall survival so I'm going to be
using two main our packages the first is
the survival package and the survival
package has all of the functions that
you need to estimate quantities
associated with survival and do
regression models with sensor data in R
and then the second package I'll be
talking about is the serve miner package
which is a great package for visualizing
survival data that uses ggplot in the
background so just to take a look at a
little bit of the couple of the
functions that we rely on so in this
data set that I'm using as an example
there are only a few variables in there
one is a time variable and so this is a
variable that's calculated from our
start date in this example date of
surgery to the end date which is the
date of death for patients who died or
the date of censoring for patients who
were last known to be alive and this is
the variable I'm calling OS years and
then there's an indicator variable which
is one if the patient died at zero
otherwise and these are the two main
variables we need to do our survival
analysis so you'll see in that first
line of code we have inside the inside
surface we have a formula the left-hand
side of the formula is the serve
function which takes two arguments the
first is the time variable and the
second is the indicator and then the
right-hand side of the equation is just
one because I'm just interested in the
overall survival right now and then
surfeit is the function that generates
our survival curve and the rest of that
code is just plotting stuff the GD serv
plat function is the mean function from
the serve miner package that does this
nice plotting so we have this survival
curve
now and it's a step function actually
every point in time where an event
occurs there's a down step so if
multiple events occur at one time there
will be a larger step down and it's the
shaded area around it as a 95%
confidence interval we have an x-axis or
years from surgery and the y-axis is our
survival probability from 0 to 1 you can
see below the plaid I up also included a
table of the number at risk and this is
important because you can see at time 0
it's our full sample size of 2119 but as
that time goes on patients die and
patients are censored and we have fewer
patients left in our analytic set and so
those estimates start to be a little
more uncertain and it's good to keep
track of kind of how many patients are
going into any estimate you're making so
if you're trying to make inference out
at 15 years you can see that you're not
as sure about what those numbers are
because we only have 27 patients left in
our data at that point ok so going back
to those two main quantities that I said
are of interest to convey prognostic
information to patients let's say we're
interested in the 5-year probability of
survival so we can get this from our
surf adoption object by passing it to
the summary and we have an additional
argument that's x you can supply a
vector of x I'm only interested in five
right now so I've just said 5 and what
this is is it's the point on the y-axis
the survival probability that
corresponds to where that survival curve
is at five years and we find in this
example that our 5-year probability of
survival is 81 percent so this is the
quantity that is commonly calculated
incorrectly you'll see this in the
literature all the time if someone
doesn't know there's a time component to
their data or doesn't know the right way
to analyze it a common way to estimate
this incorrectly is just to do what we
did in our simple example where there
wasn't any censoring and say in this
example we had 297 patients who were
dead at five years the denominator would
be the full sample size 2119 and you
would estimate that you have an 86%
5-year probability of survival and you
see that you get an overestimate here
because it's ignoring the fact that 968
patients were actually censored before
that five year point so five years for
those 968 patients we don't actually
know if they're dead or alive and so
just putting them in
nominator like that will result in an
over estimate of your of your survival
probability the second quantity that's
of interest is the some estimate of the
time the average time that patients
survive and we get this from a median
survival time which you can obtain just
by printing out your surfeit object and
what the median survival time is is it
corresponds to the point on your x-axis
your time axis at which there's a 50%
survival probability according to your
survival curve and in this example we
find that that is twelve point seven
years so this is another quantity that's
very commonly calculated incorrectly and
you'll see this in the literature all
the time and I have doctors come to me
all the time with these numbers and they
you know they're like oh I've calculated
it myself
no you haven't but um so the way this is
this is commonly incorrectly calculated
as just to take the patient's who died
at the fore so in this example we have
476 patients who died and to just
estimate the median time but that it
took you know before they died and in
this example you would say that the
median survival time was 3.5 years now
you can see that as a severe
underestimate of our twelve point seven
years that we get when we analyze this
correctly and so making these kinds of
mistakes in your data can have you know
bad consequences in terms of
communicating this information to
patients and this occurs because this
calculation ignores the fact that
censored patients also contribute
follow-up time right so if a patient was
censored at ten years we don't just
throw out their data and say oh it
doesn't tell us anything about median
survival time right because you might
not know how long it was until that
patient died but you know that they
lived for ten years and so that
information has to contribute to your
estimate of this median survival time
so another thing that is commonly of
interest in a survival analysis is to
compare survival curves between groups
and in this kidney cancer data that I'm
talking about our main question of
interest was actually whether there was
an association between BMI and survival
and this question was of interest
because it's well known that BMI is a
risk factor for kidney cancer so being
overweight or obese is a risk factor for
getting kidney cancer but among patients
who have kidney cancer it's been
observed that actually being overweight
or obese is associated with a better
prognosis and this is an idea that's
known as the obesity paradox and it's
it's common across many diseases and
it's being studied a lot right now so we
just wanted to look at this question in
our own data so you can see that my code
is pretty similar here except in the
first line on the right-hand side of the
equation now I have a variable for BMI
it's a categorical variable with three
levels for normal weight overweight and
obese and now on my survival plot I have
three curves the purple one is obese the
orange is overweight and the green is
normal the risk table at the bottom has
three rows one for each of my groups and
now you can see there's been a p-value
added to this plot and this p-value
comes from the log-rank test there are
many other ways of testing the
differences between survival curves but
I think the log-rank test is probably
the most common and what it does is it
equally weights across the whole follow
up time to test the differences between
those survival curves and there are
versions of this test that could also
wheat more heavily the early or the late
parts of follow-up if there was some
reason that that was more of interest
for your question and this p-value comes
from the served if function in R which
you can just pass your formula to that
to obtain this p-value and so in this
case we do find a significant p-value so
we would conclude that in our data the
BMI is associated with survival and by
looking at the curves there is evidence
that the overweight and the obese groups
have their curves shifted up and so they
do seem to have better prognosis and our
data another way of testing for
differences between groups is to fit a
regression model we would a common
regression model that would be used for
this as a semi parametric model known as
the Cox regression model it there are
also of many parametric forms of
regression models available for sensor
data but I'm not going to get into those
today so we would do this using the Cox
pH function so similar syntax is what we
saw before using serve fit and commonly
you would want to do a regression model
like this because you would be
interested in a multivariable model you
can imagine that in survival analysis
there are many variables that are
associated with time to death and it
easily comes to mind at the age and sex
or variables that are associated with
how long people live and so if you
wanted to say something about a variable
you would want to adjust for these
important confound errs I'm just showing
a simple example here focusing on the
BMI still so if we print out a summary
of our Cox regression model fit we would
get regression parameters and if we
exponentiate those we end up with a
hazard ratio and when you're dealing
with a categorical variable like BMI you
have to have a reference group so one of
the groups has to be fixed at one and
then your other hazard ratios are in
reference to that and a hazard is an
instantaneous probability of death and
then a hazard ratio is the ratio of two
different hazards and a hazard ratio
greater than one represents an increased
hazard and a hazard ratio less than one
represents a reduced hazard and you can
see here that both are overweight and
obese groups have hazard ratios less
than one suggesting that they have
reduced hazards of death compared to the
normal weight group and our p-value is
the same as it was before okay so what
really is a hazard ratio though so
they're kind of hard like Oh
instantaneous hazard of death well what
does that mean hazard ratios are very
commonly misinterpreted and the most
common misinterpretation that I see is
we focus on our example comparing the
obese to the normal weight group the
hazard ratio was 0.64 and you'll
commonly see an interpretation of this
as a thirty six percent reduced risk of
death but hazard ratios aren't really
risks so we can kind of get an idea of
why this estimate of a thirty six
percent reduced risk of death doesn't
make sense in our data by looking back
at our survival curve and the first
thing to think about is the fact that
these curves are somewhat parallel and
they're all going down so what does a
thirty six percent reduced risk of death
mean for one of these groups and that
context and the second thing to think
about is that if we look back at our
five-year and 10-year estimates for the
normal weight and obese groups we see
that those estimates only differ by
about 11 to 12 percent and so again that
doesn't really correspond to a 36
percent reduced risk of death so this is
a common misinterpretation of a hazard
ratio I see personally I think they're
hard to interpret and I like to use Cox
regression models to understand
directions of effects in multi variable
models and significance and multi
variable models but I like to use these
other quantities to convey and for more
information about actual differences
between groups so the last topic I'm
going to cover is conditional survival
so one of the amazing thing that's going
on in cancer research right now is that
treatments are improving people are
living longer and longer we have more
targeted treatments and more
immunological and patients are being
cured and so now it's of interest to ask
the question well does that 5-year
probability of survival that we
estimated at the time of surgery or
whatever your start time was we
estimated 81% in this example does that
really still apply to a patient who's
already lived for one year or five years
or 10 years you know and they still want
to know something about what their
prognosis is well the answer is no but
we can quickly and easily correct for
this by estimating a conditional
survival estimate and this is the only
formula I'm showing in my talk today and
it's just division so don't don't worry
too much about it but the s represents
the kaplan-meier estimate of survival
and if Y is our number of additional
years of interest and X is the number of
years a patient has already survived we
can simply divide the kaplan-meier
survival estimate for the total amount
of time by the kaplan-meier survival
estimate for the number of years of
patient has already survived to get a
conditional estimate and if we do this
in our example the table on the
left-hand side has the number of years
already survived from 0 through 4 and
then we're interested in the probability
of surviving to 5 years so for someone
at baseline at time 0 that's our
estimate of 81 percent of surviving for
five years at four years this would be
the probability of just surviving one
additional
and you can see that these estimates of
survival go up as time goes by and we
can also see this by the plot of
conditional survival estimates where
each color represents an additional year
survived and we can see that these
survival curves are just shifted up as
the time goes on and so it's important
to be able to update these survival
estimates if you're giving this
information to a patient who's already
lived for three years
what now what's their probability of
surviving to five years so just a quick
plug for a little R package I have that
does this it's called conserv it's
available on my github page and there's
a tiny tiny link to the bottom of it on
this slide and these calculations are
really straightforward but my package
will give you these estimates and these
plots and if you ever want to do this
it's a nice little easy way to do it so
that's all I have for you today my code
and data and slides are all available on
github so you can play around with this
it's if it's of interest and just gonna
leave you with some contact information
and also of reference to the original
publication of the kidney and BMI data
that I talked about that today so thank
you very much
you
you